[Music]
so I made a video recently about a
eight-pointed in if you spin buzzsaw and
that is one of the ways to make a
teaspoon buzzsaw flower and you do it if
one poin in a teaspoon the other one
makes box but there's other ways to do
if you spin both left flowers one that I
actually like even more is this one this
is a ten pointed flower and you make
that by each by making a four circle
pattern what I do is my right one point
up up up up up at the top and up the
bottom up the top and up the bottom up
up up up up up up up
now since the split time when this one's
up the other ones down so the other
points going to be going down down down
down down down down to them because my
hands are moving together so my hands
are at the top if the right place
pointing up the left foot is going to
point down and this is actually easier
it's been both a flower to make because
you kind of touch the sky with the right
and the ground the left touch the sky
ground touch the sky touch got a really
nice rhythm I can totally relax into it
so when I get people doing both left
flowers
I often this is the one I recommend
because you know at first you kind of
get through doing it at all up on the
side so make sure it's poised in front
it's done and this side switch at the
bottom eventually you touch the sky of
the right plots of ground left guy at
the right time at the left end even
knowing it you started doing a 10
pointed still star flower with a five
pointed star pointing up and another one
pointing down
all the free content I can make a lot of
free content also consider it my udemy
step by step courses even more in-depth
but and also if you really wanted to
leave the courses and you're in a
difficult financial situation just write
me and explain and I'll get you to help
me promote the fourth floor match the
world and double get you in the car
so money is no obstacle
[Music]